欢迎各位收听今天这期摆设学说我是三刀。
今天更新的时间应该是5月20号，录音也是稍微晚了一点。
大家听到节目应该就5月21号了，那么就送一个晚到的祝福吧，大家520节日快乐。
但是520我在网上看了一下子，现在基本上秀恩爱，然后晒过520节日的人很少了。
今天微博热搜也是，说大家为什么现在都不过520节了，为什么都不秀恩爱了。
我在想，现在主要是什么年轻人少了，对吧。
现在20多岁还能秀一秀恩爱，30多岁就不秀恩爱了嘛，30多岁就想要搞事业了，秀存款。
那么像我们这种40多岁的，40是接近50的，那怎么办呢，那就40多岁秀体检报告，秀健康。
然后我发那个微博，我说其实说白了，你说去哪边秀呢，普通人也不可能有一些像微博这些地方社交平台啊，对吧。
那普通人一般都是发朋友圈，朋友圈是熟人社交，所以朋友圈我始终认为，你秀什么就是缺什么，
或者说你秀什么你就在乎什么，你就怕失去什么，曾经节目里面有提到过这个点。
好，我们节目一开始呢，本来是520的这个事儿，节目可能播出是521啊，就稍微晚了这么一天。
那今天聊什么呢，上期节目咱们聊这个理想L9Leavis呢，我们提到他说不再用这个传统的超级莫里达，
而是改用UWB经常感植技术，那么也简单聊了一下UWB的一些优势，
那么有人讲说这个只有优势没有缺点吗，能不能说说缺点啊，
包括你能不能就直接把车上的那些传感器像什么超级莫里达，毫米波里达，激光里达，摄像头这些，你全都聊一遍，对吧。
让我们就彻底了解一下，就这些所谓的什么智能驾驶辅助，
车上的这些传感器到底是有什么用，有什么优缺点，有没有宣传的那么强，能不能用大白话，给大家来讲明白。
今天这期节目呢，我觉得挺好的，这次的经验也非常不错，咱们就聊一聊车上的这些传感器，
那么大家今后买车的时候呢，销售就不会给你瞎忽悠了，对吧，这明明就是一个毫米波里达，
偏要跟你说是超级莫里达，这明明是个超级莫里达，偏要跟你说是毫米波里达，
固态激光里达他也说不清楚，那个是半固态的，那干嘛用的，他也讲不清楚，
你比他还要懂，他肯定就自然不敢去忽悠你。
那么其实大家买车都希望是像我网上购物一样简单方面，最好是不要接触销售，
最好还能动不动给一些平台的补贴，
所以你看这部京东的大墙子就让我通知一下大家，给摆车全收的粉丝安排了专属618红包，
即是起到6月21号，享领红包的朋友直接在评论区点击置顶的评论链接，
有些平台可能没置顶，但是你看一下是我主播账号发到这个链接，
链接进入就可以看到我主播专属的红包页面，领取就可以了。
那么红包领到之后你在京东的App里面就可以看得到，
那么一定记得在红包有消息之内使用红包来下单。
这个红包每天可以抽三次，也可以通过每天打卡互动分享的方式，
有几率可以获得更大额的红包。
好的，那么这个小广告就打到这了，大家其实一听就明白了，
能跟京东合作确实还是比较荣幸的，
经常在什么Bilibili这种平台能看到，主播说着说着就突然变成什么转转啊，拼多多啊啥的，
就咱们这个平台起码是相对高达上一点点，
所以有需要的正好是想在京东购物的，
你反正天生有个红包你不领白不领嘛，
领了红包还能多少省一点，能省一点是一点，
是不是？好，我们回到主题上来了，
从今年开始你会发现几乎啊，
就是曾经标配的超什么雷达，
现在开始渐渐的就变少了，
那么不仅你可以看到在北京车辆上很多的一些概念车，
它已经取消了超什么雷达，
就是我们上期聊的那个理想L9 Lewis，
它作为一台量产车，
现在是一口气直接把全车身的12个超什么雷达全部给取消了，
那么因此它就没有开孔了嘛，
就看上去它的前脸啊，侧面啊，
包括尾部就更加的干净一些，对吧，
但是我曾经就是在节目里面讲，
我说这个很有可能今后四五十万的车，
可能甚至三十多万的车，
它就是一个大的趋势，
今后前脸，尾部这些地方都是没有开孔，
全部都是用UWV的这个经常感知技术，
那么要知道，
其实无论新的原车还是燃油车的自动驳车也好，
什么低速避障啊，倒车提醒啊，
它的核心功能其实都是靠超声波雷达，
那么这个超声波雷达是什么东西呢？
其实大家一听就懂，
就是我们经常在车上能看到，
车头车背那个保险杠上面，
会有那个圆圆的，
一颗一颗那个圆圆的，
也不能说是小孔吧，
它是先开孔，
再把超声波雷达给它装进去，
大家如果以前是老车主，
像我们这种年龄的话，
80后甚至70后，
早期我们买的一些车比较便宜的，
它没有倒车雷达，
那怎么办呢，
我们一般就会去到修理厂，
这些什么改装店，
找老板，
让他帮我们去定，
那个时候我记得线上购物也没有那么发达吧，
最多是淘宝去找一找，
找一找什么呢，
就是找一找像什么铁将军啊，
或者是有什么单相的，
或者是双相的，
单相什么意思呢，
单相就是装在车上，
你上车才能用，
双相呢就是它会给你一个，
就像那个钥匙的小挂锥一样的，
就像那个什么卷联门的遥控器一样，
然后你车站如果说发生什么震动了，
你那个钥匙可能会滴滴滴滴，
会响,
所以它就告诉你车子震动，
所以它就双相的，
但一般不会有人买双相，
大多数都是单相就可以了，
然后车子里面呢，
它有的时候会在那个前挡玻璃的下方，
它会装一个，
装一个这种小的液晶屏，
液晶屏呢它一般分两种，
就简单一点呢，
就是它就类似于像红绿灯一样的，
就是靠得越近，
它那个就是从绿灯，
黄灯变成红灯，
那红灯开始它就变成一条线了嘛，
它这个声音就滴滴滴滴滴滴滴滴，
對吧,
它就变成红的一条线，
那么还有一种呢就是显示距离的，
那这个就稍微贵一点，
液晶屏呢就会显示，
一米,
还有声音，
0.8,
0.7,
0.6,
0.3,
停车停车停车，
是不是，
以前有没有接触过这种啊，
这就感觉都是上个年代的记忆了，
那像这种就是靠抄什么力打，
一般都是后装的，
而且大家知道像很多的一些日系车，
它很奇怪，
你比方说雷格萨斯 你包括封填。
它会给到你倒车影像 但是不给你倒车雷达。
可能日系的车企它会是这么想。
我连倒车影像都给你的 你不长眼睛吗？
你自己看一看张艾务尼有多远 对吧？
你还要什么雷达呢？
你就不是增加我的成本吗？
其实也没有多少钱的成本。
所以他给了倒车影像。
他认为我就是给你升级了。
所以你可以理解为很多的一些日系车。
他那个年代就已经认为。
倒车影像是可以替代超人摩雷达的。
就是你车内是不需要有声音的。
但是很多人都知道。
有了倒车影像他也会回去再装一个超人摩雷达。
我们其实俗称就叫倒车雷达 对吧？
所以它本质上其实就是通过声音。
也就只能通过声音了来进行提醒。
那么加上倒车影像的话。
就是声音加图像来提醒你 有张艾务。
那么后来随着车的配置越来越高。
那么除了后像有倒车雷达。
那么前像它也会给你倒车雷达。
你就不叫倒车雷达了。
其实就叫超人摩雷达。
但是一般我们都讲。
前后倒车雷达
其实这个用词是不准确的。
前怎么叫倒车呢？
但是你一听也能听明白。
前后倒车雷达
前像是一般干嘛的。
就是说你有的时候在一些比较窄的地方。
你除了倒一把
你还要往前走一把。
对吧？
你往前走一把
你前方可能有一个水泥桩子。
或者有一堵墙
有个张艾务
你前方的雷达其实也很关键。
对不对
你只要是盲驱
你就有雷达
肯定是心里面更有底。
所以本质上来讲听声音。
去判断张艾务离得有多近。
这个就是靠超人摩雷达。
就是现在做旗舰车型的。
只要是有3，4，4，5，10万以上的这种车型的车企。
就开始
我觉得从现在开始。
可以另一事要考虑。
陆陆续续要减少超人摩雷达的数量。
今后不再依赖它
而是开始用UWB经常感知系统。
那么今天我们就先讲一讲UWB。
它为什么可以去取代超人摩雷达。
那么这个到底是一件好事还是坏事。
增加了成本到底高不高。
对吧？
那么接下来我们后面还要再给大家去普及。
其他的一些传感器。
就让今天一期节目听完之后。
大家能够对于新能源车的这个。
叫做感知系统或者叫感官系统。
能够有一个比较清晰的认知。
车上这个位置
那个位置是什么东西。
到底起什么作用
对吧？
你这样的话买车的时候。
谁家的硬件强
谁家的硬件弱
大概它是用什么样的一套感知系统。
心里面就很清楚了。
那么首先我们先讲一讲。
这个超人摩雷达
为什么开始会被边缘化。
其实它早就应该被边缘化了。
只不过涉及到成本的问题。
所以很多的一些车企还是考虑到。
因为现在电池也很贵。
激光雷达也很贵
各方面都很贵
所以这方面先暂时不动。
但是现在已经开始有人动了。
只要有一家动
那就是卷起来了
这么一卷别家不动。
你就显得不先进
是不是
超人摩雷达这个东西其实已经很老了。
在燃油车水带我刚刚前面讲的。
就甚至于我们以前。
早年我开Auto的时候。
我就已经知道这个东西了。
我的Auto装了没有。
我的Auto当年好像没装。
然后后来再换的车子。
基本上就开始陆陆续续都有了。
那么它的工作员
你其实就跟蝙伏差不多。
蝙伏是发出超声波。
然后通过碰到障碍物之后再回弹回来。
然后通过时间差去判断距离。
所以说超之摩雷达。
就是说它更适合低速近距离的探测。
你比如说倒车
侧方位停车
包括你像旁边如果有堵墙。
是吧？
靠墙缓慢的去挪车。
那么这种就在几米范围之内。
它的感知是强项
那么更重要是什么？
就因为它便宜
你想全中国那么多的车。
全球那么多的车
超之摩雷达说实话。
我当年买的时候
我记得100多块钱。
还是200多块钱。
我那个年代
我想我花100多200多。
我就已经算很能接受了。
已经很便宜了
现在基本应该没什么人去后装。
超之摩雷达了吧？
我就不知道后装市场上卖多少钱。
你这么多年过去了。
应该也很便宜了
所以在厂家作为前装厂。
什么叫前装
就是厂家作为大批量的采购。
这个成本几乎是可以忽略不计了。
它又便宜
又稳定
又成熟
所以一直都是很多的一些车企。
相当于
现在来看的话就已经是标配了。
对吧？
那么超之摩雷达其实他也要调教。
他也要调教
我记得当年我是卖奥迪的。
我觉得奥迪的倒车雷达还是不错的。
还是比较灵敏的
它会有一个就像雷达一样的车头车尾。
两个扇形
然后扇形的颜色会有一些变化。
你就知道离得是远还是近。
然后薄码的我觉得也很好用。
但是唯独就奔馳不好用。
因为我自己
我是15年还是14年前后买的奔馳。
一讲都是10多年前的事情了。
当时我买回来我就发现。
这个雷达他不如我之前的CRV好用。
他特别灵敏
就是车子其实离得还老远。
他就开始挖挖直叫。
然后离得很近
有一次就差一点点就撞了。
他的最后的离得很近。
就是直线报警
就是第一变成一条线的报警。
他又很慢
然后等红绿灯的时候。
在那个地方踩个刹车。
等红绿灯他还那边不停的叫。
你明明就等红绿灯。
车都是静止状态
我也没动
他还在那边挖挖直叫。
所以当时我就特别烦。
到了奔馳店
奔馳店跟我讲说
这个可以调
我一听可以调
我说那你帮我调备。
但他跟我说这个调节只有两档。
就是灵敏和不灵敏。
我说我以为他是可以根据距离。
然后调到一个我觉得合适的位置。
我就让他锁定在这个灵敏度上。
他不是的
他就两个档
我印象中是两个档。
是三个档还是两个档。
反正当时调了一下我不满意。
我让他调回去了
就调到那个不灵敏的一档。
我觉得那倒车状的概率就更高了。
灵敏的那一档
好歹你还能让我更早的知道。
对吧？
所以后来我又给他调回来了。
就非常的郁闷
我说这这么好的奔馳。
对吧？
这么豪华的奔馳
怎么连个倒车离达都没搞。
搞明白
就当年我就到了一个情况。
那么现在的问题就是什么呢？
就是汽车对于桿直的要求。
其实比以前要高很多。
以前的车子
就是大家花钱去买车。
那个时候也没有什么支撑价实。
大家都不知道车子的什么所谓的桿直系统。
都没有这个概念
所以以前大家知道。
就是说我车上有没有这个东西。
前面有没有
我后面有没有
只要是有就行了
那么现在呢？
现在大家玩的是自动驳车。
是记忆驳车
是离车驳入
从中间包括过渡的时候。
当时还有个什么360全景影像。
还记得吗？
对吧？
还有什么540
就是带那个底盘投射系统的。
就以前有过这么一段。
就是说360也好。
540也好
其实都是让你能够。
我们讲叫开天眼
我们要玩游戏叫开视野。
能够让你把视野打开。
那么现在相当于就让车辆有个自主。
去帮你去驳车的过程。
包括离车驳入
你人都可以下车
车辆自动帮你驳进去。
这些都是依靠传感器。
你什么窄路通行
自动召唤
全都是靠车上的传感器。
那么因此
超轮玻璃达
在现在对于这种感知要求非常高的。
一个年代
那么就开始有点跟不上了。
有点开始跟不上了。
所以你会发现
其实早几年
很多新的原车上
它是在堵这个超轮玻璃达的数量。
就说白了
为什么呢？
是因为其他的一些传感器。
其实也解决不了什么核心问题。
所以它的单体的能力不足。
那么只能靠数量来取身。
但是超轮玻璃达现在的问题点。
你就怼得再多也没有用了。
因为人家
毫米玻璃达
激光璃达这些东西。
它都是可以去
有它的常处和优势的点。
来去弥补
我们一会要讲
其实每一个传感器。
它都是有优点和缺点的。
都是在互相的进行融合。
所以为什么叫融合感知呢？
对吧？
它都是在互相融合。
每家的策略
其实就是看它融合的好不好。
我们来讲一讲
超轮玻璃达最大的缺点是什么？
超轮玻璃达其实最大的缺点。
第一个就是它指侧距离。
它无法去理解空间。
什么叫理解空间呢？
其实意思也很简单。
你比如说一根柱子。
一个垃圾桶
一只猫
还有一片塑料袋
在这个地上
有人讲撞了塑料袋也没事。
举个例子
不要那么较真
我的意思就是说
在超轮玻璃达的眼里。
它的本质区别其实这些东西都不大。
对它来讲
这些东西在系统里面就是障碍物。
就是我发射信号
遇到障碍物了
反弹回来
完了之后
我知道了
是个障碍物
那么我现在就判断。
这个障碍物大概离得有多远。
所以它只有距离
它不能理解这东西到底是什么？
那么第二一点就是。
它特别容易受到一些环境的影响。
你比如说鱼血天气。
包括积水
还有复杂的一些地窟。
还有斜坡
还有细小的一些障碍物。
我记得有一年
当时是奥迪A3
车主第二天就过来找我了。
说他们家车撞了
而且怪我
说我当时跟他去介绍奥迪A3。
有侧放位辅助驳车系统。
我当时觉得说这个怎么会装呢？
我说你装了啥
你把照片给我看一眼。
结果发现
他就是在用侧放位倒车入库的系统的时候。
他后面是一根柱子。
就是那个柱子相当于就是。
怎么理解呢？
就是晾衣服
或者说是旗干
他比旗干应该还要再细一点。
他当时认为是他能停在前面一堵墙。
跟后面一根柱子中间。
结果倒着倒着倒着。
就装到一个柱子上面了。
所以他特别容易受到一些环境的影响。
细小的障碍物
斜坡
复杂地库
鱼血
天气
击水
这些都可能会导致超声玻璃达的抽风。
那么很多人肯定遇到过这种情况。
就旁边可能明明什么都没有。
这个车就突然就疯狂的报警。
或者说就已经快要蹭倒了。
但是他就带着木机什么反应也没有。
是吧？
都会遇到这种情况。
那么更关键一点是什么？
就是超声玻璃达
其实现在他跟不上。
行动原车对于感知空间的这种需求。
或者叫空间的理解的需求。
以前的汽车是我只探测障碍物。
那么现在的汽车是需要空间定位。
那么这两个东西听起来有点像。
其实完全不是一个概念。
超声玻璃达的逻辑就是这里有没有东西。
我先告诉你
我通过声音来反馈。
我顶多再给你加一个距离有多远。
就像我前面讲的
会给你显示一个1米0.8。
0.7 0.6
那么现在的高阶支架。
它其实更需要的是你车辆。
周围的环境之间
你们到底处于一个什么样的空间关系。
这就是它本质的区别。
那么这个时候UWB就开始登场了。
什么是UWB技术呢？
我们可以看一下网上的一些定义。
UWB经常感知
是一种基于超宽带无线电信号的高精度环境感知方案。
它能实现1米级的测距精度。
它具备存在检测
生命体真监测
甚至手势识别等多维的感知能力。
其性能几乎不受温度 湿度等环境因素的干扰。
那么UWB它能够识别路排。
或者是树枝 横杆等这种1米以上的细小 悬空的物体。
那么以及包括路间 宠物或者是儿童玩具。
等等低于20公分的低矮障碍物。
并且它可以同步输出距离与方向的信息。
那么这样听下来
是不是觉得UWB特别的高科技。
其实我跟你讲 用大白话去解释。
它就是一个特别精准的进场定位技术。
就那么简单
定位技术去大家都很理解了。
就是你比方说我们天天用的什么高德地图啊？
什么百度地图啊？
这不都是点一下实实定位吗？
比方说用滴滴打车打个车什么的。
你不也要去定位吗？
定位技术大家都很熟悉了。
你不想用定位
你把手机的定位给它关掉不就行了吗？
但是什么叫进场定位技术呢？
其实最早很多人熟悉。
就是在我们的这个叫UWB数字车钥匙上面。
我相信最近这几年买车的人应该都听过这个。
是吧？
而且觉得非常好用。
你像我自己的这个Avita 11。
那我的车上就有UWB钥匙。
我每一次我根本就不用拿钥匙。
我拿着我的手机下楼靠近我的车。
那我的车自动解锁。
然后我下了车
我也不用去锁车
我转身我就走了
离开一定距离之后。
车辆自动就上锁
所以这个UWB钥匙是非常非常的好用。
自动解锁无敢进入厘米级的定位。
但是这个有一点我要提醒大家。
你的车辆即使有UWB钥匙。
它怎么知道你离得近还是离得远呢？
主要还是靠你手机。
所以你手机不仅仅是要把定位打开。
而且你要把你的软件。
比如说我的Avita软件。
它在设置里面
你一定要把它的叫做什么精准定位。
包括后台一直保留。
好像是这么说的吧？
我讲的意思大概应该都懂。
就这个软件就不能叫做什么使用时。
什么保持
一定要是一直保持。
包括它那个什么距离金色。
精度那些东西
你一定要把它都打开。
反正能点开的都得来点开。
我有一次就是更新完手机之后。
我没点开
我每次靠近那个车总是要慢慢拍。
有的时候它在边上像个呆子一样。
车门不解锁
我说怎么回事
我就问那个在线客服。
在线客服说
你看一眼手机的App设置。
果然没点开
一点开就好了
还是非常非常好用的。
那么其实最早
其实宝马是推动UWB钥匙的车企之一。
是最早的
那么现在的UWB的钥匙。
其实在新车型上已经是非常非常常见了。
那么UWB钥匙
它跟南芽的钥匙有什么区别呢？
就是这个南芽钥匙的问题是什么？
车它知道钥匙在附近。
但它不知道到底在哪。
它知道在附近
具体的位置方向不知道。
所以经常会出现
就人站在车边上车没有反应。
或者说钥匙在家里面。
但是车以为你靠近了。
它也会出现一些这种物解锁。
或者是物上锁的情况。
包括像人如果走到后背箱。
结果车尾门
你不想开车门
你只想开个尾门
你迟迟打不开的情况。
为什么呢？
因为南芽可能判断你不在附近。
它没有办法去精准定位。
那么UWB钥匙它就不一样。
UWB它可以做到厘米级。
你想厘米
厘米分厘米
厘米是什么概念
所以它这个定位非常精准。
它不仅仅知道你来了。
而且还知道你站在哪个方向。
你距离有多远
你的移动轨迹是什么？
所以简单来讲就是。
南芽它是知道有人来了。
而UWB它是知道有个人站在。
左前门或者左后门。
距离车1.2米还是1.1米。
还是这个人正在朝车尾门的方向去移动。
就这么夸张
所以他们就完全不是一个待机的东西。
那么UWB能做的其实也不只开门这么简单。
我们刚刚前面提到。
就是说行动原车现在是越来越依靠智能化。
越来越需要依赖空间感知。
空间理解的能力
那么这个也是UWB的一个常处。
你比如说它这个无感解锁的功能。
大家都知道对吧？
就是你靠近车车只有解锁。
你就直接拉开车门上车就可以了。
你靠近主驾主驾解锁也行。
你靠近后门后门解锁也行对吧？
那么再比如说像我经常用的就是自动摩车。
自动摩车其实以前是超顺摩雷达。
它是慢慢的去探测障碍物。
就像盲人模像一样的。
一点一点的摸就叫盲人摸路。
不叫盲人模像
一点一点的去摸
所以就会出现我之前讲的。
我卖了一辆Audio A3。
结果人家车主摆回去第二天就撞了。
它不是特别的精准。
而且它有时候会抽风。
那么现在它是用摄像头。
也就是用视觉剑土再加上UWB定位。
就像我们上期节目聊的L9的Levis。
摄像头负责什么呢？
它负责它看见了什么东西。
它告诉这个系统
然后UWB负责什么呢？
它是负责精确的测距测量距离。
那么这样的话整个逻辑就非常的简单了。
它是一套相对比较复杂的视觉融合加空间感知的系统。
那么也就是说它对于周围环境的理解能力。
相对于超车摩雷达已经高出了不止一个量器。
所以UWB的运用已经从数字车钥匙。
现在变成了车辆经常感知系统的一部分。
那么这也是为什么很多车企开始减少。
甚至取消超车摩雷达。
取消超车摩雷达还是比较激进的。
但是我觉得这是个大事所趋。
那么因此大家就知道。
它是为了新能源车的这种满足更高阶智能化的需求。
你想问借未来小棚。
那么像这种技术相对比较偏激进的形式立着车企。
而且它们互相之间是你看我我看你。
只要有一家用你放心。
那么肯定很快其他的车企都会去用的。
那么真正重要的是什么？
我觉得重要的就是。
现在你不能再去把这种低精度的传感器。
然后靠去堆量去取身。
没有用的
而是一定要通过这种高精度的感知。
而且通过复杂的算法去结合。
让这台车真正的去理解空间。
今后拼的是什么？
你说智能鸭子聪明不聪明。
像不像个老司机
其实就是看这台车子。
它能不能理解自己所处的这个空间。
但是这里面也要强调一点。
就是UWB它不是去替代所有的传感器。
就是车上只要有个UWB就可以了。
它本质上其实就是一个高精度的定位技术。
它不是什么环境扫描技术。
就我们讲激光力达。
其实就是在扫描权世界。
那么UWB它解决的位置关系。
而不是世界界膜
现在大家都知道
现在有个什么大世界模型。
它不是世界界膜
所以它充其量就是用来解决。
经常感知的需求
远了也不行
所以它就是适合我们前面讲。
无感进入低速障碍。
逼障
然后贴边去停车
这种场景
它其实你看这种场景。
就特别适合超人摩雷达。
所以它就是直接取代。
超人摩雷达的这样的一个技术。
那么还需要去配合摄像头。
它也才能完成得更好一点。
对吧？
摄像头就不用讲了。
大家都很熟悉了
所以它没有那种远距离去探测。
或者是感知的这样一个能力。
那么哪怕就是像素低一点的摄像头。
远距离来讲的话
也比它强得的不是一点两点了。
是吧？
也更无法去替代
毫米波力达
甚至是激光力达
是不是
那么最后我们就讲一讲。
UWB的一些缺点。
那么有优点肯定是有缺点的。
简单来讲的话
它的缺点是什么？
一句话总结
就是说不是很贵的车。
它不会用更高阶的支架方案。
这个大家认可吧？
那么如果没有用更高阶的支架方案。
它就不会用UWB经常感知系统。
所以说到底就是什么？
第一个它肯定是成本更贵。
对吧？
那么第二个就是
其实UWB更像是一套更聪明。
但是更复杂的方案。
它必须要融合在这种多传感器的。
我们讲叫做支架式方案里面。
融合感知的方案里面。
所以它不是单体说。
我给你抓一套UWB。
这个车子变得更好看了。
前保杠后保杠都不开孔了。
然后你觉得就很高级。
没有用
UWB对于算法融合。
空间建模包括车辆控制逻辑。
要求也是很高的
它不是说就多一个芯片。
多几行代码那么简单。
它是在一套融合感知系统里面。
它只是其中一个硬件。
大家就理解了吧？
所以不仅仅是UWB的成本。
要比什么超承摩雷达贵。
这个我觉得贵也是有限。
也不是那么吓人的贵。
但是UWB它一定是融合在一个更高阶的支架体系里面。
所以你说将来什么10万块钱以内的车子。
能不能上UWB有可能。
但是一定要等到UWB。
起码普及到50万 40万 30万 20万的车。
成本越来越低
然后一直卷啊卷啊卷。
卷到最后就到了10来万的车。
你不觉得也得卷了。
那可能就得上了
好那前面关于UWB取代超承摩雷达。
我们就聊到这
那么接下来我们就顺势。
讲一讲新能源车上的这一套感知系统。
包括像什么摄像头啊？
好比摩雷达啊激光雷达啊这些。
其实在讲这些概念之前。
我们先有一个比较理人化的印象。
大家有一个共同的认识。
就是说一台新能源车。
其实真的是越来越像一个人。
对不对
我们讲其实机器人也好。
这个智能驾驶也好。
其实车辆到最后
如果是完全自动驾驶之后。
它真的是越来越像个机器人。
人具备什么呢？
人其实就是摄像头相当于人类的眼睛。
超承摩雷达相当于是人的触觉。
就是手嘛？
对吧？
好比摩雷达其实有点像。
其实它比较强的是夜视功能。
夜视功能就是你不靠眼睛。
就能感知到东西是什么？
那嗅觉嘛？
对吧？
你闻到的东西
你妈妈烧的红烧肉。
你闭上眼睛你都能闻得到。
对吧？
你电梯里面都能闻得到。
有点像嗅觉
那么激光力大象什么？
其实就像这个人
它就开眼看世界
也不一定叫完全开眼。
就是说它能把轮廓描绘出来。
拿着一把尺子
疯狂的去扫描世界。
去在世界上去比划。
有多远
大概的轮廓是什么样子。
所以它是疯狂的扫描世界。
我们就一个一个的去讲。
我们先说摄像头
其实我们发现现在行动原车。
特别喜欢去卷摄像头的像素。
手机也喜欢卷
你甚至连笔记本电脑都喜欢去卷。
摄像头是多少
800万像素
1200万像素
就好像说这个像素越高越厉害。
其实摄像头真正厉害的。
它不是看得清
而是看得懂
怎么去理解呢？
因为摄像头是最接近人眼的。
对吧？
比如说马斯克
马斯克当年取消什么超市摩雷达。
然后说我要做纯视觉。
他就认为车辆
其实就是开车的人。
既然是靠眼睛来判断。
那我的车辆为什么不能靠眼睛去判断呢？
那眼睛是什么？
不就是摄像头吗？
所以理论上来讲
我纯视觉应该是完全可以。
我完全是自动驾驶的。
所以特斯拉的
这人驾驶一直是坚持纯视觉的路线。
并且他这个摄像头确实玩得很好。
我记得当年特斯拉出了好多新闻事件。
大家应该在网上都看到过。
应该是在2021年。
然后2018-2019应该都出现过。
就是特斯拉的
当年早期的1618-19应该都是Model S。
那么到了2021年。
当时是Model Y。
就是撞上了白色的什么半挂是重型卡车。
或者是白色的卡车。
那么网上反正传言什么都有。
但是官方也没有确认说。
这个是因为他之前用了什么？
奥米波利达
什么什么这个原因。
他没说
官方一直没承认
但是没过两年
应该我印象中是2023年前后。
特斯拉就直接走纯视觉的方案了。
就开始用摄像头来进行。
他的纯视觉的一个普及。
那么到底怎么说呢？
就是特斯拉他是坚持纯视觉。
那么纯视觉也有问题。
像摄像头的问题最明显的是什么？
就是他肯定是害怕环境的变化。
你比如说力光
下大雨
下大雪
包括像浓雾炫光
包括像夜里面就特别暗的环境。
暗光环境
那么都会影响他的识别能力。
那么其实很简单
你到了晚上
你就是个普通人
哪怕你不戴眼镜
你视力特别好
你别说摄像头了
你就是智商人也看不清。
而且大家会发现
就是你开车的时候。
如果是下着雨
然后夜里面
你即使开着灯光
你也会发现前方不是特别清晰。
是不是有没有这种感觉。
所以中国的车企
相对没有那么激进。
大多数车企
它不敢说
我直走纯视觉这个方案。
它还是要添加激光力达这套方案。
所以你就会出现什么情况。
就是同一款车
它可能会有纯视觉的版本。
不带激光力达的版本。
它也有带激光力达的。
叫融合感知的这个版本。
你也可以说是激光力达版。
所以我们可以理解为。
摄像头它也在发展。
但是摄像头它发展到现在为止。
或者说在
各家车企能见到的范围之内。
大家不是特别坚信。
完全依靠它能够走纯视觉走得通。
所以还是没敢放弃激光力达。
那么我们接下来要聊的。
就是毫米玻璃达
毫米玻璃达呢？
一般情况下它前面会加个定语。
比方说之前叫3D毫米玻璃达。
现在叫4D毫米玻璃达。
那到底什么叫做3D。
什么叫做4D呢？
大家买车经常会听到这个词。
我们就把它展开来聊一聊。
以后你可以考一考销售。
如果销售回答不上来。
3D跟4D是什么意思。
你能说得上来的话。
销售在你面前绝对是。
对吧就不敢瞎忽悠你了。
那么毫米玻璃达呢？
一般是分为三个主要的评断。
24G核子
60G核子
和77 79G核子。
那么它分别是对应三种不同类型的。
车载毫米玻璃达
那么我举个例子
24G核子呢？
它是属于厘米波段。
那么探测距离相对比较小。
分辨率也比较低
通常是被设计为这个脚雷达。
就是放在车头的两个脚。
那么它呢主要就是探测。
小范围的近距离的一些障碍物。
作用所谓就是实别和补忙。
那么60G核子的这个毫米玻璃达呢？
它由于会受到大气衰减的影响。
对它影响比较大
所以呢它是一般放在车内。
它探测这个近距离的精度。
和分辨率都非常的高。
所以一般都是作为车内内达。
一般就是中间的那个后置硬上方。
就内后置硬上方这个位置上。
它会去装一个
用来探测车内的成员的生命体真。
所以经常有车会讲说。
我们的行车会能够探测到车内。
有没有遗留的宠物。
遗留的孩子
监测生命体真
它用的就是这个
60G核子的车内的毫米玻璃达。
那么70G核子和79G核子。
是最典型的毫米玻波段。
然后毫米玻段
那么它的探测的距离是相对比较远的。
一般能达到200米以上。
所以一般被设计为车的前后主雷达。
就大家在那个钱宝缸的下方。
会看到一个小方块一样的东西。
它就是前后主雷达。
用来探测障碍物
这个就是毫米玻璃达的。
三个主要的频段
以后你在车子的两个脚。
看到了一个小方块。
这个毫米玻璃达就24G核子。
那么车内如果发现有。
能够探测生命体真。
那你就说
这个用的是60G核子的毫米玻璃达。
那么如果说
它是探测远距离的。
前保杠 后保杠
中间那个位置
装了一个小方块一样的东西。
那就是77或者79G核子的。
你跟这销售这么一聊。
你这么一指这么一说。
对吧？
你跟他讲说
你知道毫米玻璃达的。
这个尖色三个最重要的指标是什么吗？
你跟我讲一讲
毫米玻璃达最典型的三个尖色指标是什么？
你说你能不能说得上来。
一个是速度
一个是距离
一个是角度
所以它被称之为3D毫米玻璃达。
哦
那这个销售
如果能把这个问题回答上来。
它就算是比较专业了。
那么你在问他
你说那4D毫米玻璃达。
那这个4D还多了一个什么D呢？
哎
他如果说这个都能回答上来的话。
你直接刷卡
这哥们是相当专业的。
就是仔细的网友其实听得出来。
就是我们刚刚讲到。
他这个三个参数
速度 距离 角度。
其实都是在X轴和Y轴的参数。
它组成的是一个平面信息。
它缺少Z轴的一个高度信息。
它没有高度信息
所以它无法形成准确的空间坐标。
你看我们今天一直反复提到空间空间。
对吧？
我们是活在一个立体世界里面的。
三维世界里面的
它需要一个空间坐标。
那不仅如此
毫米玻璃达还有一个传统劣势。
就是它是低分辨率。
它分辨率不高
它知道前面有东西。
它也知道速度
但是它不一定知道它到底是什么？
就是说白了
虽然有我们讲夜视的能力。
但是它的视力其实不咋地。
它只是有这个能力。
但是实力不咋地
对吧？
就是有点东西但不多。
所以这些都是它的缺点。
但是你要知道
我前面讲毫米玻璃达有点像什么？
它不需要接住眼睛。
它有点像我们的嗅觉。
所以它的这个实力不是很强。
但是它通过电磁波去探测目标。
它对天气不敏感
你比如说像什么雨雪天。
大雾天
包括身手不见无指的黑夜。
它都能工作
并且它非常的稳定。
而且它特别擅长去测速度和距离。
所以你像什么高速的ACC自身运行。
什么AEB主动刹车。
都非常的依赖这个毫米玻璃达。
所以在激光力达普及之前。
其实它就是当时最厉害的辅助驾驶的传感器。
那么后来3D毫米玻璃达的基础上。
因为大家都在用
用的人越来越多
都觉得说缺少高度信息。
那么后来就慢慢地升级。
最后就是它通过测量。
抚养角度可以获取物体精准的Z轴信息。
也就是有了高度信息。
那么从而就可以实现精确测高。
那么测高的数据加进来之后。
那么3D毫米玻璃达不就变成了4D毫米玻璃达吗？
所以它就多了一个高度测量。
相当于就是多了一个Z轴的信息。
所以这就是为什么？
3D毫米玻4D毫米玻。
这么一解释就一听就懂了。
是不是
那么再后来毫米玻璃达的分辨率。
它也提高了
你看高度信息也有了。
然后高分辨率也有了。
所以在双重的技术网上提升的加持之下。
那么毫米玻璃达也就具备了高精度的点云图的一个生成能力。
点云图是个什么东西呢？
大家逛车展有的时候可以看到现场有掩饰。
就是比如说车展上有人来回走动。
它有点像那种热成像图或者有点夸张。
我也不知道该怎么去形容。
就是你知道这边有这么多人。
你知道现场有这么多的车。
但是它显示的那个图就会像那种像素的那种图。
就是点云图
高精度点云图点越多。
我们看比方说屏幕任何的图像生成。
其实你把它放大放大再放大。
它其实都是一颗一颗的像素。
点云图
那么可以去干嘛呢？
就是它可以有类似于激光力达的成像功能。
它跟激光力达有那么一点相似。
现在的部分的毫米玻璃达已经可以在性能上实现。
接近32线激光力达的等效能力。
就实现它高精度的点云图的生成。
那么部分的激光力达可以通过算法的优化。
我们知道你像比如说有些安卓机。
安卓手机拍个照片。
你回头一看
哎呦这个照片是优化。
我发现现在苹果的这个照片优化能力。
感觉也很明显
我有的时候拍个照片。
我手机上拍之前看到那个样子。
拍完之后
它那个图片也会闪一下。
然后就变得更清晰一些。
特别是我长焦去拍。
比方说八倍长焦去拍。
明明就是不清楚的。
结果拍完之后
那个图片闪了一下。
它突然变得稍微清楚了一点。
这不就是通过算法优化的嘛对吧？
所以部分的雷达也会通过算法优化。
实现接近64线激光雷达的等效能力。
这样一听就明白了嘛？
那么4D毫米玻璃达。
目前市面上比较有代表性的产品。
比如说像以色列耳笔公司的。
最新一代的Felix 4D。
成像雷达
还有就是华为首发。
在ADS 4.0上的这个高精度4D毫米玻璃达。
所以大家如果在网上多查一点资料。
你会发现就是华为在这方面。
还是有点东西的
那么4D毫米玻璃达。
因为增加了这个浮扬角次量信息。
而且它的这个角分辨率。
可以达到小于一度的级别。
它相比于普通雷达4000点每秒的测速点率。
4D毫米玻璃达的测速点率。
可以达到3万点每秒以上。
一个是4000
一个是3万
所以你想一想
4D毫米玻璃达跟普通雷达到底差距有多少。
那么有人讲说
你看这个测速点率都这么这么高了。
那有没有可能将来去替代激光雷达呢？
替代激光雷达
我觉得可能性不大。
或者说维持上早啊？
那么你比如说256线激光雷达的测速点率。
可以达到多少呢？
可以达到300万点每秒以上。
我们刚刚讲4D毫米玻是3万点。
256线的激光雷达是300万点。
3万点跟300万点。
所以你看
这个毫米玻璃达想要在成像上去取代激光雷达。
至少在目前的技术能看到的范围内。
可能性不大
因为它是代激查
性能上的代激查
那么接下来我们就聊一聊大家非常感兴趣的激光雷达了。
现在大家去买这个智能驾驶的车。
一般都会看代不代激光雷达。
就像大家在平台去购物。
都会去看一看有没有红包可以领一样。
那么兄弟们
京东的大墙子让我通知一下大家。
就是给白车全中的粉丝安排了专属618红包。
即日起到6月21号。
想你红包的朋友
直接在评论区点击置顶的评论链接。
进入到主播专属红包页面就可以领取。
红包领到之后
你可以在京东的App里面去看到。
注意看一下它这个红包的有效期。
不要错过了
每一天可以抽三次。
通过每日打卡
互动分享等方式
还有机率去获取更大额的红包。
所以要先领红包后下单。
入口就在评论区
好 我们接下来聊一聊激光雷达。
这个东西其实非常好理解。
你可以把它想象成。
拿着激光去疯狂的扫描全世界。
你开到哪扫描到哪。
它不断的去发射激光。
然后再根据反射时间建立三维地图。
所以它对它的价值不是看见了什么？
而是精准测距加上空间建模。
它能知道前面有什么有多远。
轮廓是什么样子
它能把汽车跟空间的感知。
还有理解
它提升到一个新的层次。
因为我们刚刚讲
它本身有摄像头
摄像头也能看到
对不对
再通过激光雷达
它就可以把辅助驾驶带到一个更新的阶段。
它就让它更加的聪明。
感知更加的灵敏
看得更加的精准
但是激光雷达的问题其实也很现实。
首先第一个就是贵。
当年马斯克为什么不看好激光雷达。
他就是觉得这东西太贵了。
他对于一个严格控制成本。
这样的一个为主的企业。
就是他那个理念
他是不能接受说车上装一个激光雷达的。
他就觉得这个成本和年马月才能降到他能接受的范围。
他完全不能接受
第一个就是贵
虽然说现在比以前也要便宜很多。
但是依然很多的一些低成本的车。
或者是低价格的车。
或者说是低配的车型。
还是不会去装
对吧？
你记住像比亚迪说。
全民支架
它是全民支架
但也不是全民激光雷达。
是不是
现在的行动原车辅助驾驶的功能。
是越来越多了
我们讲辅助驾驶
不仅仅是什么成区NOA。
高速NOA
它现在对于空间的理解要求越来越高。
所以现在有些车子。
它装的都不止一颗激光雷达。
你去像我上期聊的理想的L9 Liwis。
那一口气塞了四颗。
对吧？
那车头上方一颗
侧面两颗
后面一颗
那不四颗吗？
那它不仅仅是前装的成本高。
它后期的维修成本也不低。
左侧要如果蹭的呢？
右侧蹭的呢？
你后方要是跟人追尾。
以前追尾换个保养杠就好了。
那现在追尾
就可不是一个保养杠的事情。
对吧？
你后方是有固态激光雷达的。
那么第三一点是什么？
就是它的数据量巨大。
非常的吃算力
所以这也是我前面讲的。
你不是说装的这个传感器越多越好。
什么什么21个传感器。
26个传感器
你要知道装的越多。
它的数据的吞吐量越大。
所以
燃油车上
基本上都看不到那么多传感器的车。
对吧？
它没有这样的一个电气架构支撑。
那没有电力自然就没有算力。
你像大家最近特别喜欢去炒股。
是不是喜欢看一些这个。
什么金融圈投资圈的事。
他肯定听过一句话。
是孙哥孙女臣说的。
短期缺芯片
中期缺能源
长期缺存储
其实早在很久以前就有人让我去买存储了。
我一直觉得那个时候已经长疯掉了。
我说存储哪能买
那么高的价格
而且咱们国内的存储。
感觉也不是很内傻。
对吧？
所以我当时觉得存储这个概念。
可能离我们比较遥远。
就没想到这两年
存储晚快就长疯掉了。
我的天哪
我们不聊这些东西。
反正我们就讲
关于能源这一块
什么能源
关于电力这一块
其实新能源车肯定是有绝对的优势的。
这个是根本就不用去思考的。
所以专的存储区越多。
它的数据量吞吐就越大。
所以一定是要有电力的一个支撑。
那么接下来我们再讲一讲。
固态激光力达
早期的激光力达最大的问题点。
就是体积巨大
因为里面有360度机械旋转的一个结构。
优点是什么？
就是扫描的范围非常的广。
但是缺点就是第一个贵。
第二个大
第三个就是容易坏。
所以它就不太适合放在骑车上。
所以行业内就开始推进激光力达的固态化。
什么叫固态化
就是尽量减少机械结构。
让它变得更小
更加的稳定
更加的美观
那么目前半固态激光力达是车用的一个主流。
那么它是分为转镜式。
内部有一个小镜子高速的摆动。
还有就是MAMOS微镇镜式。
就是用微机电系统。
去做出一个极小的争动镜面。
虽然说机械结构大幅精减。
但是车顶它依然会有一个密制凸起。
那么直到最近这几年。
又除了这个叫做全固态激光力达。
那么这个全固态激光力达。
它就彻底没有旋转结构了。
那么这么一来体积就会非常的小。
但是由于它贪色的距离相对比较短。
所以它无法慎任前方的主雷达。
那么什么叫做前方主雷达。
大家会看到很多的车子。
它车顶上不是有个小机脚。
还会凸出来一块
那个一般叫做单塔料望式的顶部半固态。
讲一个激光力达
所以一般作为前方的主雷达。
那么剩下来的其他的一些位置。
一般是侧方或者是后方。
它会有一些全固态的激光力达。
所以为什么有些高端车型。
它说我们有三颗激光力达。
我们有四颗激光力达。
它其实就是一颗半固态。
那放在车顶上
我们刚刚讲的就是单塔料望式的。
那么剩下来就是全固态。
就放在侧面和尾部。
它负责去对应这些。
像什么狄矮的障碍物。
比方说拉开车门
是不是后方有来车有行人。
或者说你开车门的时候。
旁边是不是有障碍物。
比方说有个柱子
或有个吨子
你还准备刚开
刚打开一个缝
里面就滴滴滴开始响了。
那一定是有障碍物的。
这个是比较好的
很灵敏
你包括盲区的监测。
还有低速的一些极端的场景。
这些都是依靠侧面。
和尾部的全固态激光力达。
那么还有一些人会听到一个词叫做什么？
叫做可变胶激光力达。
其实侧面后面的这些有些厂家。
他也会管他叫做可变胶激光力达。
其实可变胶激光力达跟全固态激光力达。
他的这个概念是有些穿插的。
他其实主要就是为了解决。
普通激光力达的另外一个缺点。
就是他看得远
但是就是看不广
或者说看得广
他就看不远
那么有没有种可能性。
我做一个激光力达是既能看得广。
又能看得远呢？
那么这个时候就需要可变胶了。
大家都知道手机是可变胶的。
对不对
那么iPhone 17。
跟iPhone 17 Pro。
那最近不是降了1000块钱吗？
你说他们两头摄像头上来讲。
最大的区别是什么？
不就多了一个长焦吗？
那你会觉得长焦没有用。
长焦真的没有用吗？
你在某些特定的场合。
你要去抓取一些镜头的。
这个比方说景色啊人物啊？
你就是需要长焦啊？
那个时候就需要有用了。
但是呢你在买的时候。
那毕竟差那么些钱嘛？
对不对
所以激光力达你把它比做相机。
我就更好理解了
普通激光力达
它就是一个固定的焦段的镜头。
那么可变焦激光力达相当于就是。
长短焦两个镜头
那么高速的时候呢？
重点就可以看远处。
低速的时候呢？
重点就可以看近处。
那么其实今天呢？
我们把这些激光力达也好。
毫米波力达也好
撑身波力达也好
包括UWB
都应该讲用大白话啊？
解释的比较清楚了。
那么今天就聊那么多啊？
如果说我讲的呃
有些地方比较说不准确。
不严谨呢？
那么大家也可以来进行一些补充。
那么节目最后呢？
我们再把我们今天讲这些东西。
简单总结一下啊？
其实今天要聊的并非是单纯UWB。
今天我们其实想把。
就是新的原网智能化的方向去发展。
那这些东西都是必不可少的。
而且还要继续的叠带。
就是很多人说刀哥现在能不能买啊？
他不是现在能不能买。
你要看现在的这些技术。
满不满足你当下的使用。
条件使用环境
如果是满足了
你确实也该换车了。
那你不用等嘛？
你该买就买嘛？
但是我想告诉你就是。
你不管是从激光力达也好。
毫米波力达也好
还是这个UWB也好。
这些技术肯定是要继续往前进的。
百分之百的
早哪
天花板根本就看不到。
还要再往前走呢？
传感器不是谁越多越好。
性能当然是越好越好。
但是性能越好
你芯片也得跟得上。
对吧？
算力要能跟得上
存储要能跟得上
所以没有任何一个传感器是完美的。
也没有任何一套方案是完美的。
所以你一定要去试。
去了解
去多跟一些老车主去沟通。
对吧？
所以你看摄像头能看到这个世界。
但是它怕天气的变化。
毫米波力达很稳定。
但是它细节就非常的差。
那么激光力达很精准。
但是它就很吃算力。
很吃它整个系统的吞吐能力。
那么超声波力达呢？
已经很老了
很旧了
很笨了嘛？
但是它也不是义无世处。
它便宜啊？
对吧？
如果只是对基础的一些功能。
还是需要它
那么UWB并未很准。
但是覆盖的范围有限。
所以真正厉害的
其实不是说
它只有某一种传感器很厉害。
而是这家车企能不能把。
目前当下最先进的这些传感器。
全部融合进来
同时它的这一套系统。
又能吃得准
拿劣得住
能够给它一个最优化的方案。
把它们融合起来
这个才是最厉害的。
所以以前的传统汽车。
是靠什么呢？
靠机械去理解这个世界。
那么现在拼的是什么呢？
是传感器去感知这个世界。
是不是
感知能力是今后各家智能车企。
是最重要的一个就是实力的体现。
所以你看今年的北京车展。
我看有一些媒体讲说。
现在车企都是一个什么？
组专厂
车企都是拼专厂
因为今年的北京车展。
都是把这些零部件的供应商。
全部放到台前了
那么供应商都有自己的品牌。
他们也是希望在C端。
也就是我消费者当中。
能够有更好的认知。
我们以后再去买任何性能源车。
走进去第一句话
不是说我要买奔吃买宝马。
我是先问你用的是华为的支架。
还是小鹏的支架
对吧？
你用的是零德时代的电池。
还是用的这个国旋动力的。
新网达的神指
包括比亚迪的电池。
我问的是这个
但是这并不代表说。
每一个车企它只是一个。
怎么讲呢？
就是没有能力的一个组装厂。
它有这么多的硬件拼到一起之后。
它还要一套
能够把它们调动起来的一套。
这个算法
一套软件
一套系统
这个很关键
所以理解环境
理解空间
理解人
你光靠这个硬件没有用啊？
对不对
现在不是比谁家马力大。
谁家就是零百加速快。
已经不是这个年代了。
现在比的就是车子的智能化能力。
也就是理解能力了。
所以总结来讲
毫米玻璃达和激光力达。
它这些都是在不断进化当中的。
那么现阶段的激光力达的上限。
其实还是有很高很高是需要往上提升的。
那么雷达组的定位。
它现在开始呈现出了不同的发展方向。
就是毫米玻璃达呢？
开始走向全能化
激光力达呢？
它开始探索功能的细分化。
所以这两者应对的场景和职能也开始逐渐的分化。
那么固态激光力达的出现。
还是在探索这个融合感知方案的感知上限。
所以它也有很大很大的一个提升空间。
甚至于我可以讲它是刚起步。
那么更多就是为将来的L4。
以及更高级别的自动驾驶去做准备的。
所以对于像什么商用的。
包括家用的这种自动驾驶的场景来讲的话。
激光力达现阶段
是不可缺少的关键创感器。
你不管马斯克认可不认可。
至少在中国这种驾驶环境里面。
我觉得激光力达至少在我可以想象的范围之内。
应该是不会被抛弃掉的。
好 那么以上就是本期节目主要的内容。
感谢大家的收听
小宇宙喜马拉雅
如果大家没有订阅的话。
听到这的话
帮忙用发财的小手指点点订阅。
那么喜马拉雅的听友在手机的播放页面下方有月票。
免费的月票帮忙投一投。
谢谢大家了
那么每期节目我们会在评论区抽取三位。
赠送由人言计提供的苹果翠两代。
没有错
从今天这期节目开始。
我们每一期抽取的听友。
赠送的就是人言计的苹果翠。
每个人两代
那么也别忘了
京东的大墙子让我通知大家了。
就是摆设悬殊的粉丝。
会安排专属的628红包。
就在我们的评论区。
即日起到6月21号。
想领红包的朋友
直接评论区点击链接。
那么进入到主播专属的红包页面领取就可以了。
红包领到之后
在京东的App里面是可以看到的。
那么大家记得在红包的有效期内使用。
那么每天红包可以抽三次。
那么通过每天的打卡。
互动分享等方式
还有几率可以获得更大额的红包。
所以先领红包
后下单
入口
就在评论区
那么下面是关于上期节目的留言互动。
上期节目我们聊的是理想L9 Lewis。
然后我对于800V的主动询驾。
我是特别喜欢
那么有人讲说充值了充值了。
这个怎么说呢？
你让我去批判他
我怎么批判呢？
跟大家一样
说L9的车主素质不好。
随便断停车
可是我身边
我确实也没见到那么多。
有肯定是有
但是也有其他的品牌的车主乱停车。
是这个话在网上
即使你说的话是对的。
但是你说话的这个氛围。
或者说你主观是怎么想的。
你又是一个汽车的车评人。
那你就更不能讲这个话了。
但是我觉得音频这一块。
大家对我的宽容度还是比较高的。
所以呢想了解的那就听。
对吧？
你要觉得说你主观一定得判断说。
三刀你是到底站着个品牌。
还是不站着个品牌的。
你抱着这个来去听的。
那你骂我两句
我觉得也能理解
你要是如果不听
那我也能理解
但是整体来讲的话。
你说这车到底有什么缺点。
增程本身我也不是说特别喜欢的一个技术。
但是它有的人就需要。
对吧？
我一直在讲买增程的人。
其实就是买燃油车的那波人。
虽然说看似把燃油车给换了。
实际上它开的还是个燃油车。
只不过是带电池的燃油车。
只不过现在电池越来越大的燃油车。
所以你平时虽然全程都是用电驱动。
你都是在充电
但是你为什么你全程用电驱动。
你都是在
而且看重的又是大电池。
你怎么就不买个电车呢？
那你骨子里面不就是还是对这个续航。
你是不信任吗？
那你续航不信任
你还是要有油箱
你不等于还是买个油车吗？
对吧？
讲的有点绕
这就是你要让我吐槽就唯一的点。
但这个我在节目里面没讲吗？
我仍然讲了
我仍然还是讲了
那除了这个你还让我吐槽什么呢？
吐槽车机不行
芯片酸粒
它哪一项差
吐槽硬件不行
设计有缺陷
哪里有缺陷
吐槽它配置
那配置都快到顶了。
还能吐槽什么？
吐槽价格
人家价格30万出头。
今天小鹏的GX上市。
对吧？
大家也看到了
这个定价顶配34万多吧？
然后入门版是26万多吧？
大家也可以评论去聊一聊。
小鹏的GX
你觉得它这个定价怎么样。
那么有机会我去试了这个车。
也可以在节目里面跟大家来评价一下。
这个车我是怎么看的。
好
我们来看看上期节目的听有留言。
第一位叫做江峰先生。
江峰先生
他说在我看来
你想L9 Libis这个车型还可以。
颜值不错
但是我本质我不喜欢增程。
可能也是因为跟刀哥早期。
吐槽增程有一定的关系。
当时我就觉得
你都买电车了
为什么还要搞个发动机。
还要去体验游车的感觉。
虽然说开起来都是全程用电。
但是它毕竟是有油在里面。
有油箱在里面
但是从刀哥的一起讲L6的节目开始。
我就慢慢的关注理想。
后来我还订了一台理想的i6。
2025年的12月份提的车。
你看
他喜欢理想
但是不喜欢增程
最后买了一台理想的电车。
他说从提车的时候。
车机系统是8.0的版本。
一直到今天升级到了8.5的版本。
5个半月升级了5次。
每一次升级都有非常实用的一些更新。
你比如说8.4的单踏板。
8.5的远程驳车。
就是驳出车位等等这些功能。
那么让车主感觉这个理想。
其实它真的是挖空心思。
在去想怎么去提升用户的使用体验。
那么现在我也是很喜欢理想这个品牌。
算是从一个路人变成了理想的粉丝。
那么我今后再换车。
大概率我还是会选择理想。
所以你看
在网上真的你骂的人很多。
但是实际上买的人也很多。
而且我发现了很有意思的现象。
就是在我们的那个知识星球。
我已经记不得看到有多少人。
晒自己的车室理想了。
而且就最近这几个月。
有没有知识星球的兄弟吗？
是不是我们知识星球上提车晒出报告的。
晒提车报告最多的就是理想。
动不动谁谁谁提了个理想。
动不动谁谁又提了个理想。
所以这就是一个很有争议的品牌。
但是争议也代表着他流量大。
关注度高
你说是不是
下一位听有叫做肉丝的捷克。
这个ID很熟悉
他应该之前也中过奖。
他说我高中时候就跟着同宿舍的哥们。
听摇滚乐
也是听纳瓦拉涅盘。
听钢色安肉丝就是枪花。
听米太利克
听玛丽联曼森黑豹什么唐朝凌碟。
说大学同班同宿舍的哥们玩摇滚。
那么跟着他呢？
听的就更多了
什么谢天笑
AK47 Green Day。
还有好多我都记不得了。
那么毕业之后呢？
这哥们一直坚持自己的音乐梦想。
现在组建乐队很受年轻人的追捧。
圈内的名气也是越来越大。
很佩服他的坚持
很羡慕他把爱好做成的事业。
谁呀？
圈内的名气
你能不能这期节目评论去告诉我是谁。
以后给我要张门票。
没事我也去听听他的这个。
这个现场的乐队表演。
其实我到现在
有些什么音乐节
我还是特别想去
但是因为陈家立业。
或者叫陈家有娃
不叫立业
就陈家有娃之后
就淡繁周末
去想要组织去看看什么音乐节。
我带我媳妇带我女儿去过一次。
哇
他们就觉得就一个字类。
第二个就是现场东西不好吃。
因为音乐节现场也会有很多的一些。
这个小吃美食嘛？
就是什么什么臭豆腐干啊什么？
什么这个铁板油鱼啊之类的。
他们就感觉吃也吃不好。
然后呢现场明星又不多。
他当时就喜欢有个。
那个明星我都记不得叫人名字了。
都长得有点女性化的。
那个头发嘛？
他把扳只眼睛给遮到的那个。
那谁我真记不得了。
唱歌真的男不男女不女的。
我不太喜欢他
我老婆当时就要听他的这个歌。
好
他也是亚洲最后出场。
然后旁边呢还有一个舞台。
他一般舞台这个大的园区里面。
会分好几个场子嘛？
然后还有一个他唯一熟悉的就郑军。
郑军也是最后出场。
然后就听那个郑军的。
就另外一个舞台
两边各自听了一下。
那我喜欢谁呢？
我喜欢二手玫瑰
然后我当时我说你们就去那边听吧？
然后我去听二手玫瑰的时候。
老婆孩子都没来
他们对这个完全不了解。
什么什么玫瑰还是个二手的。
那我从小我就喜欢二手玫瑰。
刚出道我就喜欢龙哥。
对吧？
懂遍不量西遍亮啊？
就正经人都不会听这个歌的。
但我当然觉得我的天哪。
很有味道
中国摇滚乐我觉得这就是。
就是不可磨灭的一颗符号。
真的
浓墨重彩的一个乐队。
我觉得他早晚会火。
以前我一直以为他这个昂德国让的乐队。
但是以前确实很昂德国让。
但是现在参加一些什么综艺之后。
就没有那么奥布朗当了。
就单身了
他确实哥们美妆博主出道嘛？
现在短视频里面也很火。
那我就
他没火之前我就很喜欢二手玫瑰。
所以你说正于音乐节也很难搞。
我有的时候我看到音乐节。
现在的乐队说实话我也不是很熟悉了。
然后我媳妇他们
现在就我老婆最近也在跟我讲。
说他身边有些人家里收入还没我们高呢？
他们每个星期每个月都去追演唱会。
演唱会的门票动辄一两千两三千。
然后他们是怎么呢？
他们不是说去专程去单独看演唱会。
他们是一家人去旅游。
安排个两天左右三天的行程。
然后其中一站是看演唱会。
他说他老公要不我们也这么安排。
我说可以没问题
对吧？
这孩子只要不补课。
你想听谁的演唱会。
对吧？
我来我来买票
我们一起去追一追。
不就是看个氛围吗？
所以我老婆讲说
这个演唱会现在真的是氛围非常好。
就是他现在因为看基金嘛？
他说这个里面
就从消费角度来讲的话。
就演唱会的消费
现在是非常火热
非常火热
行啊？
这是第二位
第三位是叫Sunshine V5i。
他说我就在抚药体系。
摄后换玻璃一般一个小时就好了。
而且现在的小的玻璃破损点。
是可以修复的
不见得都要换
这倒提醒我了
就是现在的修复技术。
应该是比以前要先进很多。
所以有机会你看这期节目。
能不能再留个言
或者你发一些相关的。
介绍的链接在评论区。
我想了解一下
就是现在的修复技术。
跟以前的那种修复技术。
对于现在玻璃的破损点。
包括玻璃的那种裂痕。
它有没有一些
就是五连前跟五连后。
有没有一些什么样的变化。
或者你找盾牌
把你的联系方式丢给我。
我们不行就在隔壁的小声流刀。
做一个联线
我就关于玻璃修复这一块。
我们能不能展开聊一聊。
也是非常感谢这位叫做Sunshine的听友。
服药体系
跟我们讲换玻璃
其实一个小时就好。
对吧？
你不管是去第三方的。
就是服药的售后
还是去到4S店
理论上讲就非常快。
而且也是
我觉得操作难度不是特别大。
它是一套标准流程。
都会有专业的工具进行辅助。
好
那么以上就是今天这期节目。
所有的内容给大家收听。
那么中奖的听友可以联系盾牌。
盾牌的微信是46415254。
跟他来联系领奖
那么同时我们还有更多的原创内容。
在Bilibili叫摆车全说。
在抖音小红书视频号号快手。
这些平台叫做三刀砍车。
单人旁砍大山的砍。
那么还有我的个人微博。
叫摆车全说三刀
那么公众号摆车全说。
也是每天都有更新。
大家如果想联系我。
或者想进入到我们的社群。
也可以添加微信
46415254。
今天这期节目就到这里。
我们下期接着聊
拜拜